have you [ __ ] every pizza so far I
just I've [ __ ] the last two pizzas hey
what's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you from
Roberta's and Bushwick Brooklyn where
I'm joined by Jay Kevin
Steve and Eric you know them as broken
lizard the legendary comedy troupe and
good news for comedy fans super troopers
2 is in theaters now and that's why
we're here at Roberta's one of the most
celebrated pizzerias in New York City to
give a STONER classic meal the tribute
that it deserves we're gonna be cycling
in some of the best frozen pizzas the
world has to offer to see which one is
king and first things first
simple question delivery versus DiGiorno
do each have their place in the pizza
world I have always been delivering when
I was a boy around 11 I started getting
onto a frozen pizza routine and I
basically ate frozen pizza for about 4 4
weeks in a row lunch dinner fudge dinner
frozen pizza frozen peas you're a kind
of sort I love frozen peas I did like
the Stouffer's that's the one that's a
great one that pizzas [ __ ] delicious
I have to ask you guys how often do you
get asked to guzzle maple syrup every
day a lot a lot maple syrup is a bad
thing to guzzle I you know I drank two
and a half bottles he drank three we
went into like a real major sugar coma
after that we laid in the dark and just
shook I tried to throw it up it wouldn't
come up too thick and then afterwards
you know things came out of you that you
don't remember putting in like a
fossilized robbing fetus that was a
whole lease as a strange one that was
weird holy-o's well I can sit and talk
to you guys about script lines and edit
notes all day long but I'm hungry I know
that you guys are too big screening
yesterday so let's work off that
hangover with the first pie
all right first up we have le owes the
company was founded in 1963 and Great
Neck Long Island it's made with 100%
real cheese and no artificial flavors or
additives
I bet le o--'s dead I was long dead what
do you guys think Ellie I'm so yeah
Ellie oh it's gone we doing it mm-hmm
this is not a glamour pizza no you know
this one elementary school and they have
pizza for lunch yeah yeah this is the
picture that you would have Wrigley
Field serves a pizza that tastes this
good I'm really brought me back to my
childhood that Elio speaks to things
that Elio steaks very seriously they
make a very big deal about the real
cheese thing which makes me a little
suspicious about the world of frozen
pizza well that becomes such a
distinguishing quality and then of
course the rectangular shape do you have
any opinions on the triangle versus the
rectangle is the real cheese making a
big difference for you guys if I was
gonna choose my shape I would go
triangle because that first triangle
bite is is key I also like a fold I'm a
full guy yeah and so you can't fold the
square I prefer the square because it
tends to have a crispier crust you know
this is very much win a tournament in
Little League Pizza I like the
rectangular shape overall it's a
thumbs-up for me I'll go thumbs up also
it's been nostalgia of the shape yeah
this brings back some nice memories I
you know I prefer a little cheesy er a
little saucy er you know I'm not gonna
[ __ ] this pizza but you know it does the
jelly eat it it does the Java all right
up next it's an institution the
tombstone original this brand was
founded in 1962 in Medford Wisconsin
tombstone is a five cheese pizza that
uses mozzarella cheddar parmesan Asiago
and Romano it also has a zesty sauce to
it when I think tongues did I think of
Kurt Russell yeah me too Sam Elliot Jay
this is a five cheese blend you know how
does it stack up against the one cheese
beats that we had lower it has different
like levels and flavors and I'd tell you
if I were gonna set out to make a pizza
I might stop at four cheese's but then
these guys said now we'll go one more
we're going five g's yeah
I think I would [ __ ] this pizza all
right next up we have DiGiorno for
cheese variety and the company has been
making pizzas in the US since 1995 and
is of course best known for its slogan
it's not delivery its DiGiorno car it's
a little fat for my taste it looks like
it's gonna be a little bread II good
okay pretty good tasty and the crust the
bread is tasty but this is more like I'm
it's like a Sicilian sized pizza you
know like you would cut into the
Sicilian squares yeah but if I'm gonna
have extra anything I want extra cheese
uh-huh I don't want extra bread all
right yeah I'm more of a thinner crust
Pizza Pizza proves that you really need
to stop at four cheese's I think that
fifth cheese made that last pizza a
little crazy now that I taste this I
mean at the risk of saying I like
everything that's in my mouth at the
current moment I like this pizza next up
we have the frozen margarita pizza from
right here at Roberta's the pizzas are
cooked in a wood-fired oven and then
blast chilled before being packaged you
can buy them at Whole Foods here in New
York or online at Fresh Direct and it
looks on an eyeball level different from
everything we've had a ton of us today
small I can see some dredging it looks
trendy to me it looks like a trendy got
like a leopard-skin thing going on I'll
still take a healthy piece of this big
one I think the big one guys see that's
delicious
nothing about the Uni like a million
slices of this pizza does it taste
better than you thought it would
mhm yeah that a leaf on it yeah Jenny
loves leaves you can taste the Leafs
Basel III basil II like leaves I feel
like if I'm coming home after a Super
Troopers two and I'm still a little
residual high or whatever this is not
the pizza that I know now if you're high
maybe you don't want to hit a
michelin-starred restaurant like maybe
you just want to hit the drive-thru it
if you want something good fake cheese
you know right although I enjoyed the
hell up
no that's the thing it's good ass pizza
I'm not gonna [ __ ] that pizza
I would like to see you [ __ ] up it
actually looks like you did [ __ ] it
already and just flattened out you know
I'm a fan of what labor it has delicious
flavor will be flavor like a basil
flavor and I mean it's not it's not like
moots you know time now give me some
wood some beets a little punch in the
face
yeah thumbs up thumbs down met where are
we on this two thumbs up
whoa oh [ __ ] a thumbs down match to the
good people Roberta's thumbs up but I'm
going frozen peach I'm going something
different 3/4 3/4 3/4 up 3/4 up would
you [ __ ] this pizza I would take it on
to date and see what happened alright
fellas what we've had frozen pizza all
day long but the real test is to see if
it stacks up to the real deal we have a
fresh margarita pizza from right here at
Roberta's is it a relief to eat
something like this after eating all
those frozen pizzas
I would not only [ __ ] this pizza I would
let this pizza [ __ ] me oh he'll eat this
look at me wrong it's good and I'd [ __ ]
it to another delicious fresh Pete's out
of the oven you can't beat it especially
cuz Roberto walked in here and delivered
this personally I know I looked Roberto
in the eyes I wanted to love his pizza
yeah the frozen pizzas they're not going
to compare yeah but let's crown a king
when it comes to the frozen pizzas what
was everyone's favorite which one was
for cheese the for cheese was DiGiorno
that's the one for me okay I'm going
frozen pizza I'm probably going to
journos I'm not going with these guys I
like that v cheese I like the tombstone
the best as I said I like bread mm-hmm
so I'm gonna go to your house he's gonna
nod DiGiorno's to me tombstone it's just
it's the spot it's nostalgic it's
everything that I want in a frozen pizza
but nothing really compares to sitting
down at the restaurant and eating it
here so my overall crown going to
Roberta's Super Troopers to make sure
that you see the movie first we feast
you already know and if you're looking
for that pizza that's not out of the
freezer that's fresh that
delicious that you can have with a date
and not feel like a loser Bushwick
Brooklyn roberto's that's the place to
be
until next time Internet good fold man
good
[Music]